Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner's Welcome to another episode of Conner's
clinic live. Glad you joined us. We have a very special guest that interviewed me not long ago,
so we've gotten to know each other. Dr. Diane Mueller is a specialist in mold and microtoxid illness,
Lyme disease, a whole bunch of different things, so Diane, good to see you again.
Yeah, good to see you too again, Dr. Kevin. Thanks for inviting me to your program here.
Yes, as far as what I do, so you know, it's like in these types of fields that we work in, it's the
yes, I treat Lyme and yes, I treat mold, and I do all this, but what I really do is treat the whole
person, because as I think we know with so many different diseases, like with Lyme disease and mold
illness in particular, when they're great mimicors, so you know, somebody could have fibromyalgia,
chronic potato, chronic pain, or brain fog, or neurological problems, on and on and on, they don't
even know they have Lyme and mold, so a lot of times people don't even come to me because of Lyme
and mold. Some people certainly do, but other people come to me because wow, they had fibromyalgia,
and they heard a podcast about that might be connected to Lyme disease, and they're really looking
to get the answer. So a lot of what I'm doing is really helping people figure out the why behind
their chronic disease situation. I love that. It is so true that people have been labeled by some
practitioner, or by themselves, maybe Google eats their symptoms, and really they've never gotten
to the root of it. So their their calling, their disease, you know, a named disease that is really
just a collection of symptoms, never getting to the root cause. And as you know, and you alluded to,
there's sometimes several root causes to their disease. Yeah, you know, it's a funny thing. I think
so many times we get we get so excited about the label, right? We go so far as like it's so
common to see that we get so excited around when we've been sick for so long, where I'm like,
okay, somebody finally told me that I have chronic fatigue syndrome or somebody finally told me
I have IBS, and unfortunately, I think there's so much power that these labels have, where sometimes
people have this misunderstanding that the label is almost like like the end, like they finally made it.
And in many ways, the label, you know, to clinicians like yourself and myself and many of us out here,
the label sometimes is really more of the beginning. It's more of saying, okay, we can put a tag on it,
but we still have to go back and figure out why, why do you have that tag?
Well, it's like anybody with a diagnosed autoimmune disease, they have MS. Well,
Lyme could be a cause of that, mold could be a cause of that, heavy metals could be a cause of that,
you got to get to the cause if you're going to help these people.
Yeah, absolutely. And what we see with all those things you just mentioned, like one of the things
that winds up happening that leads to things like mold and lime and metals causing MS, Parkinson's,
other neurological diseases can be due to blood brain barrier disease. We're the brain, the blood
brain barrier, which is largely supposed to keep things out, right? So we have this barrier that's
supposed to be fairly tight and certain things are not supposed to have easy access to our brain.
And with blood brain barrier disease, it's one way, there's other ways, but it's one way that
these toxins more easily get into the brain. And these toxins create an oxidative process in
the brain. They create this chain reaction of inflammation. And what we see is that we actually
see something called neuronal apoptosis, which is where our nerve cells actually die. And that's
what's happening and leading to some of these types of neurological diseases, or in cases like
Alzheimer's, we see there's some research studies that are showing that the plaques that are
seen with Alzheimer's actually have an immune function to them. So it's theorized that when we see
this link between things like like lime disease, for example, and Alzheimer's, that what's really
happening mechanistically is that the body is creating these plaques as a way of almost trapping.
And these toxins and these infections in order to help our immune system work. Now of course,
in this example, this is the body going haywire and the body is trying to do a good thing. And then we
have a less good thing happen, but a lot of the mechanisms that we see in the body that are
leading to disease are really in part, these toxins getting into the wrong place, creating this
widespread neuronal inflammation. And that's the pathway through which these diseases occur.
Well, we see so many of these things are becoming normalized by medicine today. But everybody knows
somebody that's 90 years old that has their complete mind and memory. And yet people are losing
their memory in their 50s. There's something going on around what would you do to assess and then
try to help a person that's in that category? Yeah, you know, it's so interesting. It's like when we
look at things like dementia, right? So if you go in classically and do something like a
mini mental status exam as a common questionnaire that's used in the the dementia world, for example,
if you go and you get like a true, say, memory, dementia type of workup, most of the time,
if it's very early onset and say you don't do as well on some of these exams, but it's not like
really dementia yet. You're largely told to watch and wait. And so we don't have any sort of
medications that are actually really designed to prevent from a pharmaceutical standpoint,
prevent the progression of dementia. So you can have something like mild cognitive impairment as
it's called, which you know, in the lay person world, we might call this brain fog. And there's no good
conventional medicines for stopping this. There's certain tests like the mini mental status exam
that is going to help us evaluate from just a questionnaire standpoint where you're at. There's
other tests like the neurozumer by vibrant wellness, which looks at antibodies to the brain and some
of the brain tissue. Look at if we're seeing inflammatory markers looking for signs of leaky brain.
So those types of things are really great to use diagnostically as a initial, say, way of
actually analyzing where you're at. It's not telling us they don't tell us the root, but they give us
that baseline to say, okay, well, here's where your brain function is now. And then the next phase is
actually to figure out what the root is. And then we use things, we can use things like the neurozumer,
like the mini mental exam, in order to actually track our progress along the way and make sure
that we are seeing the positive changes in this example in our brain. And some of the lab tests,
you know, really are widespread. Like definitely really proper line disease testing is important. A
lot of the line disease testing that's done in conventional medicine is very problematic. It's
not very thorough. It has a lot of false negatives. Mole testing is really big metals like you
mentioned. So we want to test for all those things. We want to make sure that is one of the things I
always like to emphasize is like as we're talking about some of these more complicated type of lab
tests, things that people may have not thought of, we never want to forget about the basics too. So it's
like we always want to remember that the whole picture of wellness and brain function really is
a puzzle piece. So we want to make sure we're doing our full thyroid pattern. We're looking at the
adrenals. We're looking at micronutrient levels. We're making sure we don't have leaky gut and, you know,
doing our GI stool cultures and our seabows and all these different things depending upon your
symptoms. So it can seem like a lot if you're listening to this. And it can be. But that's the point
of working with, you know, a clinician like yourself, like me, like several others in the field.
That are really looking to say, okay, for the uniqueness of your condition, these are the root cause
based tests we need to do. And then last use some of these other things like the, you know, like the
neurozoomer, for example, to really make sure we're tracking our progress along the way.
I like that. I know some patients might have a pushback on spending money on different testing.
But if you don't look at the big picture, it's so easy to miss things. And you hear, I mean,
how many times have you had a patient that said, I've been to 20 other doctors? It's because
maybe the 20 other doctors didn't do a real complete job of looking at the big picture because it
might be something way out in the outskirts that is causing a lot of your symptoms that has never
been addressed. Yeah, it's so true. It's so true that I feel like most of my patients at this point
have seen a dozen people, you know, people practitioners or more. So I hear that really, really commonly.
And it's really hard. I feel like I spent a lot of my time counseling people on understanding
why it's good to invest their hard earned dollars in figuring out the roots. And I get it. You know,
it's like our medical model is really messed up in this country. The way we're doing things, I don't
know of a perfect medical model in the world, quite frankly, but it's not a perfect model. You know,
we've a lot of a lot of problems with the medical model. And when it really comes down to it,
if you ask my, you know, some of my patients, you know, I have a lot of patients in the MS Alzheimer's
type of world. And a lot of people that are much less progressed, you know, brain fog and basic
stuff like that. But if you ask some of my Alzheimer's patients, you know, they would go back to 20 years
ago when they had brain fog. And if it cost them some thousands of dollars, you know, a few thousand
dollars or whatever it is to get well, they would, you know, hand that over 10 fold to get them out
of that situation. So, you know, it's not said to scare anybody, but he means, but I think we really
need to work to change our orientation to medicine as an investment that we all pay for it now or later.
You know, if we don't pay for it now, the disease progresses. And we're going to spend so much money
on things that insurance doesn't cover later in life if our body is falling apart because we
haven't figured out what the root is. So not many people get out of that. Some people do. But for the
most part, I think it's a really, it's like a pay now or pay later type of situation. And it's
unfortunate that that's what it is. But it's your health and it's your life. So I hope this that people
hear this and feel motivated and empowered to kind of take charge. Yeah. Now you mentioned earlier,
I want to touch back on that the blood braid barrier disease. Yeah. So tell me how you would
treat that person because that's got to be pretty common out there. It's real common. And it's,
you know, it's another point when we're talking about the roots where a lot of treating it is
understanding what's causing it. So this is, and this is another area where it gets complicated
where it's like important to work with all the different root causes because high cholesterol,
for example, actually will cause blood-brained barrier disease. You know, so sometimes my patients,
when they come in and they're complaining of chronic fatigue syndrome, for example, and you know,
we're doing all these tests and I'm like, well, we got to throw in a lipid panel. We got to look at
your cholesterol. Why? I ate a good diet. It's never been high. It's like, well, you've never tested
this, you know, you haven't tested this in the past year or so. And if cholesterol levels go up,
we can actually get leaky brain from that. Another example of something that causes blood-brained barrier
disease is a gram negative bacteria. So this class of bacteria, when they die, they secrete what's
called an endotoxin. And this endotoxin will cause blood-brained barrier disease. Now this class
of bacteria is real common, right? So chronic UTIs are usually caused by a gram negative bacteria,
small intestinal bacteria overgrowth, which has a lot of bloating for a lot of people, constipation
and or diarrhea. That oftentimes is gram negative bacteria overgrowth. We can have that in our
stool. So many different types of illnesses have this category of bacteria that will actually cause
blood-brained barrier disease. So we can do various things, but the really the fundamental root of
working with blood-brained barrier disease is removing the cause of what is actually creating it.
So what would you like to leave people as far as, you know, if there was like, I just a couple
key points, you know, because I think a lot of people that have chronic illness seem overwhelmed.
So if you could just like narrow things down to a couple key points for people to focus on,
what would what would you say? So the foundational methodology that I use in my practice is metabolic
synergy working on your your all your metabolic system. So your hormones, your micronutrients,
all of these types of things, lifestyle. And in this order, typically detox and then killing,
right, our microbial balancing as I call it. So we don't want to jump to that last one, don't they?
People want to jump to that last one. And it's like, and we want to get to that point where it's like,
oh, we finally found the bug, you know, and it's all the germ theory of disease, germ theory, you know,
germ is cause disease. And germ certainly have a big influence on disease. But for so many people,
the body when we have these long term chronic things as it exhausted the immune systems depleted,
the nutrients were depleted, you're not absorbing anything. And when we're asking you to do the work
and killing things and detoxing is a lot of work. I've seen that it works really well to build up
the body first. And that's why for many people I do start the metabolic work before the lifestyle,
those can be used interchangeably. But the point of using the metabolic work first really is that
oftentimes for people and they're chronically ill, sometimes doing the lifestyle stuff, it's like,
oh, we don't even have energy to do that. So it's like, let's first start with giving you energy.
If you have energy for the lifestyle stuff, get on that right away. Remember that this is in steps
and get, you know, you're listening to this and you're getting to the root. I would definitely encourage
you step one, take a first step and really think about how you can rebuild your body in a simple way.
And look at what that means. Like, does that mean doing a basic micronutrient test? Does that
mean starting yourself on a B vitamin? Does that mean getting your thyroid tested? But just if you
haven't done some of those basic things before you jump into these other things, and I encourage you,
if you have some of these widespread symptoms, I'm talking about to do so. But before you do that,
start with the basics. Build up first, help your body get a little bit stronger so you can do this.
And then the second thing I will say is just to move on to the lifestyle thing that probably one of
the number one areas in the lifestyle component of this matrix that I see to be problematic for people
that's a really simple hack is lymphatic work. So the lymphatic system is the system,
vasculature, and these lymph nodes that have that carry around, they help our body carry out toxins
and trash and help our immune system flow. And it gets these these area, the lymphatic vessels get
really backed up. And in part because lymphatic flows through a fascia, it moves really only when we
contract our muscles. And oftentimes when we have chronic illness, we're not moving our body a lot,
and the lymph gets backed up. And oftentimes when we try to save, we try to detox, for example, before
the lymph is moving, that can really make people feel really sick, right? So a really easy hack is
just go on YouTube, any other type of platform like that, then look up self lymphatic massage. There's
a ton out there. You want to definitely focus on starting with your neck first. And you can go get
professional lymphatic massages as well. But it's super easy to lay in bed at night, give yourself a
two minute lymphatic massage, very easy, very gentle. It's a lifestyle hack. And oftentimes when we
do this, and we get to the detoxifying stage later, we can very much for many people don't we don't see
oftentimes as many bad curk simers are called type of reactions when we have detox reactions or
die off reactions, because the body is able to move and the fluids are able to move appropriately.
So it's a small hack that you know, it's two minutes a day, but I really see this making a huge
difference for people and get them prepared for all of the more intense aggressive treatments.
When you're dealing with people, how much of your practice really boils down to education
and getting people to understand that it's a process and it takes time and they people get impatient,
they want to, you know, they're used to the standards of care medicine where they take some
beds of diazopena, they feel better in a week, you know, it just isn't that way when you're really
going to heal your body. How do you, how do you deal with that? I actually have a chapter in my book
called Dr. Hopping, when to hop and when to stop. I go through that exact topic and one of the things
I counsel people on in my book is like, how to think about when it's when it's truly like the not,
not the right fit or it's not working because there's definitely times where it's like, this is
not the right philosophical, it's not the right fit. There's no right one right clinician for everybody,
you know, that's why there's good thing there's so many of us, right? And so some of it is like really
beginning to analyze like when do we actually move on, when do we stay put? But I do do do a lot of
counseling and education on that and answer to your question. I think there's a lot of really
of managing expectations because we are so used with like basic things like, oh, I have a headache,
pop an Advil, pop a Tylenol, whatever, like we're so used to these, these conventional things that
just make the symptom go away that there's, I think the societal, almost the subconscious belief
that symptoms are supposed to go away quickly. And so there's definitely a lot of counseling,
but the other thing I wind up doing for my clients is I use the the MSQ that questionnaire that
goes through and looks at a lot of symptoms. And you I use that at the very beginning and everybody
rates it. And about every month or two, I have them redo it. And I have found that that really
helps my clients a lot because one of the problems I think with long term disease is the brain is
more oriented to what is wrong than what is right. So my example of this is I had a client come in,
her number one symptom was face tingling. And it was her number. She had a bunch of symptoms,
a number one thing. It was so easy to get that one or like gone, it was just gluten for her.
So she came in, we run lab tests, while the lab tests are coming in, took her off gluten.
Three weeks later, she comes back to go for the labs. As like, how's it going? You know, what's
anything changed? It's like, no, I feel the same. So I do what I always do when people say that,
which is still ask them all the questions around what they came into see me. And they and she's like,
oh my gosh, Dr. Diane, the face tingling is totally gone. I totally forgot. I even had it.
And it was the number one thing she came to see me for us. So, you know, it's just an example of how
the brain like, you know, it's it was a normal process. It wasn't any like forgetfulness. It's just
the brain is not oriented to track what's right. It's oriented to track what it needs help with.
So I use, you know, the questionnaire throughout my practice to help people see, like, okay, this
isn't, you know, this isn't a magic pill, but look, you had, you know, a higher is worse in the
questionnaire I use. And so it's like, you had 122 score. And now you're down to an 80. So that helps
to give the brain the feedback loop, you know, to say, okay, I actually am getting better. And that
helps a lot. I see with the kind of this whole thing around like, okay, it does take longer than,
you know, popping a pill, which isn't curative, you know, it's just palliative.
Right. Now you touched on one thing about a very special thing that you have done your
written book. So tell us about your book. Yeah, the book is called, it's not in your mind. And to,
you know, properly, I feel like I identify this thing that so many people feel like or have been told
after seeing dozens of clinicians and you're not really having much luck or having like one thing
wrong on the lab and try to do something and it doesn't really get better. So it's really a book we
focus a lot online on a lot of mold. We do talk about parasites and viruses and other toxins as well.
And it's really looking at chronic disease and a solution and a strategy for getting well. So I go
through in there, I go through protocols I use, I get through a lot of research mechanisms of
actions. Why this is happening? Labs to use. And then I do link people even to my online store where
they can have access to some of these types of things at, you know, physician grade supplements and
those things as well to help them with their journey. That's fantastic. Well, I just want to thank you
so much. You are a wealth of knowledge and I think our listeners are just going to love what you do.
What is your website in order for people to connect with you? Super easy. My line
doc.com. I appreciate you being on it. I'm going to have you want to get if you will be
so kind to do so and grace us with your presence again. I would love to Dr. Connor. Thank you for
having me. All right. Bye bye. Bye bye.